I will not be the first congratulate you
but your podcast gentleman and I think
many of you know it it's a phenomenon
it's fantastic fantastic you have and
it's called armchair expert and I got to
go on this podcast and loved it it's so
much you're so much fun to talk to and I
was curious we were talking backstage
about the one part of hot casting that
is the part you don't think about when
you sign up for one which is reading ads
yes and so it was curious like how do
you feel about the fact that okay you
get to probe people's minds talk to them
there's witty banter and then you got to
stop it and you got to read these ads
how do you feel about it well it's I
think it's a double-edged sword
Coenen where's your sword I mean the
upside let me just keep it positive yeah
thank you advertisers for keeping us in
business but a lot of the advertisers
insist that I use the product so that
when I talk about it I'm not speaking
out of my can yeah so one of them was
the good folks at Sleep Number they said
go to a Sleep Number showroom
pretend you're pretty woman pick
whatever you want so I found a bed there
the most expensive one they sold it
manipulates itself it's a transformer
and it folds up and like this it has a
foot warmer and in real life prior to
this Kristen and I had been debating
like went what age are we allowed to get
one of those craftmatic old people
adjustable beds yeah when can you get a
hospital before like you know that it'll
get you up on your you know yeah its own
volition
so shoot you out of bed yeah so we got
this sucker we have not looked back
whereas we watch TV zero gravity we're
like this we have a foot warm right it's
like a chilly 70 out in LA and we've got
our foot warmer on and we're zero
gravity and I gotta tell you I enjoy
speaking about the the Sleep Number
because it's made my life a dream so you
get it you got a free one yes just
because you got you got to do their ad
that's right no an accident
Sleep Number we go to the sponsor and
coning ah come over chop into the zero
gravity in my bed come over to the house
and we'll jump into bed yes with you and
Christian yes yes this is a real offer
not the first invite either if you
recall that's true I ask that you bring
these abodes neither here nor there but
yeah come over and see what you think
okay I guarantee you'll be reading those
ads in no time okay do you find it at
all awkward that does it ever interfere
with sexual relations the fact love the
banking yes we've been together for 12
years we have two kids
so that's scheduled like a month out May
14 we're gonna we're gonna engage us
again maybe in you swing by that date I
know that I don't know that date is
burned into my brain we put on a good
show
yeah yeah you know when you only get
after it once a month boy its fiery you
know yeah because the anticipation right
you know like you're there was snow on
the ground last time we did this I'm
kidding my wife's a Hellcat nice she
can't keep me out of the rack yeah I
don't know what products he represents a
Hellcat and I can't keep her out of the
rack what is that who says that that's
Shepherd yeah
[Applause]